[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you okay
you okay I'll go out on camera I'll put
it on camera a photo on camera if you
want to go to the police I saw you know
I saw they were coming after you
that's why I followed you okay what is
it really
what can I do I do get in
they call me give me the bathroom for us
so that when we give me the helmet hmm
you okay
go go
so you saw something there I was just
driving and they just saw something
acting funny these guys on their helmets
and they attack this Bravo just waited
for himself
and he fell on the floor they tried to
jump it back and then a min ago look I
just saw them attacking another person
so that's why it's important Bravo
sisters be very very careful
recently it's absolutely madness these
guys haven't pets they're just doing all
sorts of stuff I spoke to a brother last
week his house got robbed knifepoint you
know and the sister was there his mum
was dead dad was there I saw him in the
restaurant but that the guy was like
crying grown man you know make sure your
doors are locked
make sure you take precautions be very
careful swallow it
yeah it's very very dangerous be very
careful my laptop was stolen two times
you know in my car they're using these
devices bounces it please be very very
very vigilant inshallah what lion is a
reminder you know look this is life
anything can happen each other so wanna
be very careful be very vigilant